a major new study has shown that teenage
boys are six times as likely to suffer
from heart problems from the vaccine as
they are to face hospitalization from
the wu flu itself meanwhile a recent
survey shows that people who haven't
gotten the vax already almost certainly
will not get it so the ruling class is
trying to force everyone to get the
vaccine just one year after dr fauci
himself admitted that vaccine mandates
would constitute an unacceptable
encroachment on people's freedom
a lot more to get to on top of that
audiences cheer as an ex-special forces
dude beats up a woman ron desantis
swings back at joe biden over kovid and
former president george w bush compares
the capital horn guys to al-qaeda on the
20th anniversary of 9 11. i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from ike heard
who quoting joe biden says but our
patience is wearing thin
he is literally threatening us now lol
now now you're just catching on that
he's threatening us yes there there have
been threats the whole time implicit
threats slightly less implicit threats
like when the left burned the country
down and killed people and and now joe
biden say my patience is wearing thin i
played real nice for some time but now
it's wearing thin they're probably going
to take me off of the internet for for
reading this report for reading this
this new study from the science but
whatever i'm going to read it anyway
teenage boys face a greater risk from
the vaccine than they do from covid
this is uh from the telegraph it's a so
it's a british report it's according to
major new research from the united
states children who who face the highest
risk of a cardiac adverse event are boys
age 12 and
through 15. following two doses of a
vaccine according to a new new research
from the united states
uh the findings come as professor chris
witte who is england's chief medical
officer prepares to advise the ministers
on whether or not there would be a wider
benefit to society from vaccinating
children so the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization delivered
at this verdict saying that the margin
of benefit of giving 12 to 15 year old
boys the shot was quote considered too
small
and they're citing the low risk to
children from this virus so
you can look at it look up the article
if it hasn't been taken down already
look up the study if that has not been
taken down already this is something
that we have
suggested for a long time on this show
and a lot of conservatives have pointed
this out they've said for young healthy
people some young healthy people
face a greater risk of danger from the
vaccine than they do from the
coronavirus and many people have been
booted off of social media altogether
for saying that we've been smeared and
it's called it's called misinformers and
lying we're not following the science
well here's the science here it is this
is the this is as the science as it gets
and
it's showing that for young healthy
people perhaps doesn't make the most
sense to get that shot
we've heard this from these young people
themselves there's a student athlete who
took to tick tock i'm sure this is going
to be taken down too he took to
tick-tock to say he was a totally
healthy student-athlete he was looking
forward to his senior year and then he
gets the second shot of the vaccine and
he comes down with myocarditis i am in
the hospital right now
with heart complications from the kevin
19 vaccine
and i want to inform as many people as i
can about the risks from taking the
vaccine that i wish someone would have
told me
so i am a division 1 student athlete
with no prior health issues
and i got the second cobot shot tuesday
and within four days i have been
diagnosed with myocarditis
and was told that i probably won't be
able to play my senior season now
it is a side effect from the
coveted vaccine
and it's really not being reported or
addressed and it is a serious issue that
we should all be informed about before
making this decision it isn't right for
people to be forced to take the vaccine
because there are actual side effects
like this that could happen to you
and the ncaa should not mandate student
athletes to get the vaccine because of
what could happen to so many fellow
student athletes on health issues which
has happened to me
what you're going to be told is that's
fake news that's fake look it's probably
not real and okay even if it is real if
you even if he really is a student
athlete look the plural of anecdote is
not data actually it is but uh look it
the science shows the vaccines are safe
and
okay
okay
let's say that the vaccines for the vast
majority of people are totally safe and
it's totally fine and the odds of anyone
including a teenage boy facing these
heart problems is very very very low
okay
what the study is saying is that
their risk of facing heart complications
here is much much much higher than their
risk of facing hospitalization from the
virus itself so why would they get the
shot why would they get this shot
there's really not much
argument for it especially because we're
told that the way the vaccine works is
it protects you the person who receives
the vaccine from the worst complications
of coronavirus
so you can't even really make the
argument that teen boys otherwise
healthy teen boys need to get it and
risk myocarditis to protect
old people or fat people or people who
are at greater risk because we're told
that the vaccine protects those people
so there's really no argument for it and
this is why i think the united kingdom
right now
is reversing their plans for the covid
vaxx passports the british government
was pushing to mandate vaccine passports
for nightclubs movie theaters other
large public venues and the health
secretary sajid javid is now coming out
and saying no they are going to reverse
course on the passports it is only two
days ago that nadim zaharwe the vaccine
minister says that he didn't like
vaccine passports but it is the right
thing to do has it overnight become the
wrong thing to do
there's no overnight about it first of
all there's a lot of defenses as we've
just gone through some of them that we
we need to keep in place here because
this virus hasn't gone anywhere there's
still a pandemic so of course we need to
remain cautious but we just shouldn't be
doing things for the sake of it all
because others are doing it we should
look at every possible intervention
properly so you ask about vaccine
passport so i think it's fascinating i
think most people probably instinctively
don't like the idea i mean i i've never
liked the idea of saying to people you
must show your papers or something to to
do you know what is just an everyday
activity but we were right to you to
properly look at it to look at the
evidence
well what i can say is that we've looked
at it properly and whilst we should keep
it in reserve as a potential option i'm
pleased to say that we will not be going
ahead with plans for vaccine passports
oh okay look we were absolutely very
very right to try to force this on the
public but you understand
then they pushed back a little bit so
now we're not going to do that yes yes
yes well i don't know what is this a
south african accent or a new zealand
accent i don't know it's not great what
can i tell you that's not not i do my
vouching better than my british
the point that he's making here because
at the beginning he says what no it
didn't change overnight okay it didn't
change overnight
is this being
pushed because of the science or because
of the politics and he admits it's the
politics
he says people don't like it
and so we're we're not going to do it
we're going to keep it in reserve in
case we get the chance to do it but the
people are pushing back on us and so we
are not going to do this
absolutely right this is because people
especially some conservatives some
factions of the conservative party in
britain
said no thank you beyond that
beyond the
uk speaking more broadly including here
in america the simple fact is people who
have not gotten the vaccine already are
most likely just not going to get it
ever no matter what you do short of
going door to door and sticking them
with a needle there's a survey just came
out
from cnbc and change research just found
this past week
the the vast majority of unvaccinated
americans 83 percent do not plan on ever
getting it
this was taken among 1775 respondents
that it found that there's a little that
can be done to persuade them
the vast majority of the unvaccinated 84
percent
said they would not get the shot even
even if the vaccines had no
side effects
87
said employer mandates would not move
them to take action either so they keep
changing the way the question is asked
well what if we did this and what if we
did that and what if it were like this
and it's still 83 84 87 say
no thanks we're not going to do it
so the only thing you could do is
even beyond a mandate which still
wouldn't convince a lot of people you
you really have to put teeth on that
mandate and the fact is even the people
now pushing the mandates just a year ago
said absolutely not that would be an
encroachment on liberty one of the
people who made that point
dr fauci himself you know i don't think
we've ever had a situation
where you mandate it for the general
population
so let me give you some example of
mandating
so i'm a physician i see patients in my
hospital
right literally out the window here
across the hall
at the nih clinical center
during the flu season
the administration of the hospital
mandates
that i have to get a flu vaccine
otherwise i won't be able to see
patients the way i usually do
that has not happened ever to my
knowledge
at a national level or even at a state
level so i can see the individual
institutions
mandating a vaccine i don't see it on a
national level merely because of all the
situations you have
upon encroaching upon a person's freedom
to make their own choice of their own
health
so like all other fauci predictions
turns out this one was wrong too because
what happens now we're seeing the
vaccine mandates and the whole public
health establishment is pushing for them
but the one part that fouchy got right
is the american people do not like them
and they almost certainly will not work
one way to protect yourself
go check out ring i love ring alarm i
love ring alarm because it gives me
peace of mind whether my wife and i are
home at the same time whether i'm away
from home and she's there whether she's
away from home and she worries about me
i don't know you know listen somebody
could break in do me harm it's just
great to be able to keep an eye on your
home
wherever you are
whatever part of your home you want to
keep an eye on the ring alarm system is
so easy to install even i can do it it's
really inexpensive and it is extremely
high tech i love these guys i rely on
these guys i have given it out as a
housewarming gift right now protect your
home anytime from anywhere with ring
alarm go to ring
dot com slash knowles k w l e s for a
special offer on a ring alarm security
kit today
build the system this is right for your
home have it up and running in minutes
you will know if anyone's creeping
around your home is it the delivery guy
is it a bad guy is it your mother-in-law
which is scarier go to ring.com
ring.com
knowles the debate over vaccine mandates
comes down to freedom right and we we
talk a lot on this show about how
freedom has been misinterpreted in
recent years on the left and on the
right
okay i think a lot of the problems with
why the conservatives have not been all
that effective over the past several
decades a lot of the problems we face
now in our political discourse are
because even we misunderstand what
freedom is
freedom is not the ability to do
whatever you want whenever you want it
that is not what the founding fathers
thought freedom was
that is not what classical statesmen
thought freedom was that's not what the
christians thought freedom was that's
not what the ancient pre-christian
pagans thought freedom was it's not what
conservatives thought freedom was until
just a few years ago
freedom is the right
to do what you ought to do
okay and i'll i often give the example
of the drug addict i'll give you another
example right now
this comes from mixed martial arts
there was a big fight the other night
in which a giant hulking ex-special
forces dude
beat a woman beat her up
a giant hulking dude beat up a chick and
this was considered a great victory and
people applauded for that the fella's
name is alana mclaughlin i don't know
what his real name is but the name he
goes by is alana mclaughlin
he is the second openly transgender
woman
a dude to to beat up women in the mma
and he won his debut on friday night via
submission at the com combat global
preliminary games in miami
he's 38 years old he used a rear
chokehold against celine provost
ended the match three minutes 32 seconds
into the second round here's what he
said he goes i want to pick up the
mantle that fallon put down
fallon fox is another dude who went into
the ring to beat up women and cracked
open a woman's skull and people
applauded for that too they said yeah
yeah buddy you go you co-crack that
woman's skull equality freedom
he did that
he became the first transgender woman to
fight in the mma in 2012 and then this
fella says right now i'm following in
fallon's footsteps i'm just another step
along the way and it's my great hope
that there are more to follow
behind me
freedom right in this freedom this is
this is freedom according to the modern
liberal definition that many people on
the right
have bought into well it's his it's his
it's his freedom
if he feels like a woman then he gets to
just pretend to be a woman he gets he
gets to be treated as a woman he gets to
dress up like a woman and compete in
women's sports it's his freedom and by
the way the woman that he beat up
she agreed to do it
right let's not let's not make her into
a victim here i mean sure a hulking
special forces dude just bruised her up
but
she agreed to do it it was her consent
just like the woman who had her skull
cracked open by fallon fox she consented
to it
so it's her freedom too and look we're
all consenting to watch this sick sick
match
right this psychopathy in a ring and so
it's all it's all free it's all good as
long as you agree to it isn't that great
the heroin addict just decides to shoot
up you you tyrants better not tell him
that he can't shoot up a bunch of dope
and kill himself why that's his freedom
right
right no i don't think so
i don't think so what we saw happen i
didn't watch it
obviously
but what other people saw happen at the
mma is the refutation
of feminism
transgenderism
the whole sexual revolution and this
whole misunderstanding of liberty okay
feminism says men and women are exactly
the same they're identical there are
some superficial differences
but beyond superficial differences
they're identical and that's just not
true men and women are different they're
different physically they're different
emotionally they're different
ontologically
they're just different okay
a woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle according to the feminists just
not true
men and women both need one another
transgenderism is the logical
consequence of feminism
if men and women are exactly the same
well first first then you're gonna have
to redefine marriage because men and
women are exactly the same so the union
of two men and the union of two women
has to be by just following that logic
it has to be the exact same as the union
between a man and a woman and then
following that logic a man can be a
woman and a woman can be a man because
there's actually no difference right
except
when they get into the ring and the men
crack the women's skulls open and then
you realize oh wait there is a
difference ah no but i'm but i was told
there is no so i get i must be imagining
this it must be an illusion
it was just the luck of the draw that
fallon fox cracked that chick's skull
open right it was just
it could have gone the other way the
chick could have cracked his skull open
except they never do because men and
women are different
the whole sexual revolution
do men and women relate to sex in the
same way
i don't think so when a guy when a
single guy goes out with his buddies and
they want to get up to no good they are
thinking about sex in a different way
than women are that's just a fact
leon cass the bioethicist
has this idea
it's called the wisdom of repugnance he
said there are certain things that just
at a gut level
we just
we just find icky okay and this is not
fully reliable to our understanding of
moral problems but
it is somewhat reliable think of incest
consensual incest where there is no
possibility of producing a child
right there you can't really make a
utilitarian argument for why that's a
bad thing because there won't be a child
there won't be any extra now these two
people are consenting they love each
other it's no big deal and yet
we just have this aversion to it we just
think that's just
there's something wrong about there's
something wrong about a man cracking a
woman's skull open
and
if you're if you're bought into the
logic of liberalism and progressivism
and all these modern ideologies you
can't really explain if you're
conservative you can't explain why it's
wrong but if you're a modern you can't
quite explain why it's wrong but you
know too
you know too that it is wrong
speaking of hitting people who are
weaker than you
ron desantis is swinging back at joe
biden joe biden is blaming ron desantis
as best he can for the uptick in covid
cases notice they don't they don't
really talk about the uptick in deaths
quite so much
they don't even talk
very much about the uptick in
hospitalizations it's always the cases
because
the cases don't really matter the
question is death and
hospitalization so
the other reason biden's hitting
desantis is because he thinks desantis
has a good chance of being the nominee
so whether biden's running whether kamal
is running he wants to weaken desantis
so desantis comes back
and he takes joe biden's logic and he
flips it on its head
here he comes from washington dc
instituting an unprecedented mandate
which even his own people have
acknowledged in the past is not
constitutional that's not leadership and
i think the problem i have with joe
biden more than anything this guy
doesn't take responsibility for anything
he's always trying to blame other people
blame other states this is a guy that
promised when he ran for president that
he would shut down the virus if you look
now there's 300 percent more cases in
this country today than a year ago when
we had no vaccines at all so his
policies are not working he's doubling
down on things they're going to be very
destructive for the livelihoods of many
many americans and obviously going to be
destructive to our constitutional system
and the rule of law and so these are
times
when you believe in that constitution
you got to stand up absolutely right
this is more evidence that ron desantis
is a very sophisticated politician
because what joe biden is doing here is
he's pushing the problems down to the
states he's got the whole media to
defend him and say all the problems with
covet are coming from florida
which is obviously not true right during
the epidemic
andrew cuomo was probably the worst
governor in the country uncovered
desantis was the best and yet the media
blamed desantis
and and made
cuomo into a deity before he got booted
out over that
sex scandal was really over the coved
scandal so desantis is flipping and he
goes hey buddy you're blaming me because
the coveted cases are going up you're
the president you said that you would
reduce covic cases what you're going to
let little old ron de santa stop you
from doing that take some responsibility
this is your fault and you lied now
there's a woman who
frankly i know there are a lot of people
up for the republican nomination for
president
this woman if she wants it i think she
has my endorsement i think she has my
vote she put the situation here with
biden and the covid mandates and his
patients wearing thin she put it better
than just about anyone i've heard
talking about my patience is wearing
thin what you're talking to
as long as your patients don't get as
thin as that hairline i think will be
all right i am not your child
yeah what and i'm showing up natural
you're talking about your patience is
wearing this these people have lost they
acting like they you know what i'm
saying i'm saying like they paying your
bills and you
i saw that little clip i said oh he's
crazy
he really think he you really think i
miss her
my patience is wearing thin i need you
to get out on that boulevard and bring
me my money yeah my pimp
the hell is wrong with these people it
really says that [ __ ] out of his mouth
but our patience is wearing thin you
bald hip see see
see
i thank god see that danny calling me
right now trying to save trying to save
my mouth
i could not have said it better myself
and i think that on a deep level maybe
people will use slightly different words
that's the feeling of a lot of americans
who are not going to pay any attention
to that
where do i vote for that woman where do
i give me a mail-in ballot so i can vote
for that woman for something
when you want to protect
not just the security of the ballot but
your own security your own digital
security i would strongly recommend you
check out lifelock researchers have
determined that email phishing attacks
and brute force attacks are the two most
popular and successful methods that
cyber criminals use for ransomware and
extortion attacks on corporate networks
these attacks are very simple to attempt
they're very difficult to detect and
they can come with huge rewards for
cyber criminals good thing there's a
lifelock it seems today every week you
read another story about some huge cyber
attack protect yourself and your data
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats for instance your
social security number for sale on the
dark web if they detect that your
information's potentially been
compromised they will send you an alert
you've got to protect your information i
know you think no one's after your
information no they're after
some famous guys information they're
after some big but they're after your
information okay
a
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure here now no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton join now save up to 25 off your
first year by going to lifelock.com
knowles lifelock.com
knowles for 25
off subscribe and start listening right
now to morning wire on apple spotify
wherever you listen to your podcasts
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear
our president has decided to go this
really awful route and mandate vaccines
for all businesses for with over 100
employees that includes us here at the
daily wire
i'm not going to use the exact words of
that tick tock lady but that's exactly
what we're feeling right now joe biden's
not going to tell us to go out onto the
boulevard and make him his money all
right
we are fighting for our employees we're
fighting for our freedom we're fighting
for you and we are telling joe biden to
go pound sand all right we're pretty
fired up about it that's why you should
tune in to catch an all-new episode of
backstage tomorrow with me ben jeremy
matt and drew it streams tomorrow at 7
00 pm eastern 6 pm central on
dailywire.com and on our daily wire
youtube channel do not miss it we'll be
right back with a lot more
political alliances are shifting
there's a woman she was very prominent
in the the metoo movement rose mcgowan
she's a hollywood actress
she is i think traditionally on the left
i think she was pretty firmly on the
left and she saw behind the curt okay
she saw
what the power structures are really
like certainly within hollywood and more
broadly within the liberal establishment
of which hollywood is a pretty
significant part and so rose mcgowan has
been changing her
her relationship to politics
so much so i didn't think i would see
this day she has just come out and in
her state of california
is endorsing larry elder for governor
do you want a society that has gangrene
on its leg
but puts on a fancy suit
and pretends it's not there while they
hobble in pain
or do you want to just stop
look at reality
take your medicine
clean up the wound and run
run free
why not change
why not go big why not put a stake in
the heart of evil because that's what
this really is this is good and this is
evil i know this place has it in it to
be better
i know it does
i've met so many good people in this
country not the elites
absolutely not and then we have the
jennifer siebel newsomes of the world
why
why do you keep choosing that why do you
keep electing that
don't listen to their buzzwords cult
leaders
which is what these people are
i would know i grew up in one like i
said
they massage your mind
they keep you in fear
they keep you in doubt now notice she
mentioned this newsome woman she's
referring to gavin newsom's wife and the
story that came out just came out on
dave rubin's show the mainstream media
are totally not touching the story
what rose is alleging and i have no
reason not to believe her and dave has
seen the emails and he's got the
receipts
is that there was a pressure campaign to
shut up rose mcgowan six months before
the harvey weinstein story came out
before the metoo movement really
really broke
and gavin newsom's wife was one of the
people
according to rose
who was pressuring her and said hey
what do you need what do you need to go
away what how can we make you happy
now does that mean we're going to pay
you off does that mean we're going to
give you some position does that mean
we're gonna put you in a movie what does
that mean
and
i have no reason not to believe her in
this specific case and we know that this
is a broader problem we know that the
swamp or the blob or the establishment
or whatever you want to call it
it looks out for itself and it's very
tied in together hollywood with the
press with the democratic party with the
entrenched interests
it's all
with big tech with the educational
establishment they're all really tied in
and they all really look after each
other and so when there's a real scandal
like the weinstein scandal don't as
people forget it now because weinstein
is a punch line
harvey weinstein was probably the most
powerful man in hollywood
they come out
and pull out all the stops to try to
protect one another
and so what rose mcgowan is seeing is i
think what a lot of disaffected
democrats and liberals are seeing
which is they might say you know you
know michael
michael i don't agree with you on
everything and our views on the issues
might be
fairly different if we're talking about
i don't know what it marriage or or
immigration or the america's role in the
world or what a citizen is we actually
might have different views on let's say
on every single political issue for that
matter
but there are these matters of policy
and their matters of issues and then
there are broader matters of the
political order the regime and what a
lot of people are seeing is regardless
of what i think on immigration abortion
even whatever
the ruling class is so sick and so
corrupt and so undeserving of its
authority that they're going to vote for
somebody else
they're just just to crack it up i think
a lot of people voted for trump for this
reason they said i don't care what he
thinks about war about immigration about
it i don't care he's not one of those
people and because those people are bad
they're really bad
so i'm going to vote for anyone else
that's an important thing
and so our democracy
gave us an attack on that ruling class
now the ruling class strikes back rob
reiner
good old meathead from from all in the
family
uh a great character on a great show rob
reiner his father's carl reiner
hollywood legend
rob is a huge lib he is about his left
wing as they go and i'm not going to
attack him for his
particular
political views i just want to point out
the hypocrisy from these people he says
whether it's vaccines voting rights
climate change or investigating a deadly
insurrection
what wasn't oh my god the only deadly
insurrection last year was was blm
we're sick and tired of being tyrannized
by an ignorant minority enough
let majority rule okay
so the position of
rob reiner is let majority rule uh we're
for democracy
i hear this from my liberal friends and
relatives they say michael we're
pro-democracy we're just trying to save
our democracy okay what about the
democracy in texas that just voted to
outlaw abortion
well no that's different well why is
that different well because there's a
constitutional right to an abortion
okay so you're admitting that we need
some limits on the democracy well no
well sure constitutional limits okay
that's
that's first of all second of all show
me the right to an abortion in the
constitution you don't see it it's not
really there they had to invent that but
okay you've granted now that there are
some limits on the the democracy
okay good so now you defend our our gun
rights our second amendment rights to
keep and bear arms well no that's
different we need the people to be
allowed to vote why is that different
because that's an actual constitutional
right you've just granted that there can
be some limits on the democracy and that
there have to be so there you go there's
one that's spelled out it's not in the
invisible link in the constitution like
abortion is there it's right there in
the bill of rights we'll know that's
different we need to be able to vote on
this
okay what about trump
right trump in an election that was
conducted in a much more fair manner
than the 2020 election with the
widespread mailings in the violation of
state constitutions
and the accounting that went on for days
and days and weeks and weeks
donald trump wins he wins the election
isn't that our democracy no it's it
can't be that's when
when the people vote the wrong way
according to the left that is
illegitimate
it's it's probably caused by russian
collusion
it needs to be fixed by the courts but
then when the people
vote the right way that's
even if it violates some provision of
the constitution that's democracy we
need more democracy it's it's deeply
hypocritical
the reality is we live in a
constitutional republic at least we did
and the way the constitutional republic
works is that the people have a say
and the states at least at one time had
to say and the federal government has
some power and there are limits imposed
by the constitution and that's a complex
system of government
today the way our our government works
is very different
i meant to get to this point last week
but i'm glad we have time to get to it
now
when joe biden came out and
gave his vaccine mandate
there were
a lot of conservatives who said that's
not how our government works
right and i get what they're saying what
they're saying is that's not how our
government is supposed to work
that's not you know when i watched
schoolhouse rock and i am a bill up on
capitol hill that's that's the way our
government works the congress proposes
laws and it's then the senate votes on
them and then it's signed or
or vetoed by the president and if it's
vetoed it goes back to the house and if
they can muster a veto proof vote then
it goes back and it becomes a law and
then the courts can decide whether or
not it's constitutional if a case is
brought up there you go that's american
democracy so that's not how it works
that's
i hate to be the one to break this to
you but it turns out our actual system
of government our lower case c
constitution not the uppercase c like
the document but the actual the way our
government is constituted is very
different the way our government is
constituted is that some senile old jerk
named joe biden can just give a decree
and pass it to an administrative agency
pass it to osha and then osha will just
do whatever it wants and and if if you
do not comply it'll bleed you with fines
and fees and all sorts of things that's
the way law is actually made very few
laws are made by the congress
most laws are made by these kind of
unaccountable bureaucrats
and that's just the way it and we can
we can not like that
you know we can disapprove of that but
the reason the left is so good at
wielding political power is that
they are engaging in politics in the way
that it actually exists
and conservatives are engaging in
politics in the way that schoolhouse
rock told us that it's supposed to exist
but that's imaginary that's not that's
not how it actually works and so we're
gonna feel really morally pure and we're
gonna and we're gonna know
what what the the framers of the
constitution debated
in the 18th century and it's not going
to result in jack diddley because
the left is engaging in the real
politics
are democracy or see as rob reiner's
when
peaceful mostly peaceful
conservatives storm into the capitol and
don't kill anybody and even though the
washington post and the new york times
reported that they killed a cop it
didn't actually happen but they go and
maybe they break a window and they steal
pelosi's electorate that's a violent
deadly dangerous insurrection when blm
kills dozens of people and burns down
courthouses and police buildings and
steals a bunch of sneakers and and
steals people's private property that's
a that's a mostly peaceful protest okay
that's our democracy in action
and george w bush the man that
republicans backed for president twice
george w bush came out on the 20th
anniversary of 9 11
and compared i think
the horn guy from the capitol
to al qaeda
the security measures incorporated into
our lives
are both sources of comfort
and reminders of our vulnerability
and we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come
not only across borders
but from violence that gathers within
there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home
but then there's disdainful
pluralism in their disregard for human
life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
this is really weasely language because
bush won't come out and say what it
seems pretty clear that he's saying
that he's going after
the capital riot people
now when i first heard this i said oh
yeah yeah you're right blm
and antifa and al qaeda maybe they are
it's a little harsh pal but sure maybe
they are children of the same foul
spirit
they they have a disregard for human
life obviously blm's killed a lot of
people but when he said they attack
national symbols
seems to me there that is a pointed
reference to the capital now you might
say blm burned down police buildings
federal courthouses but
you might call that a national symbol i
suspect he's talking about the act this
when you think what are the national
symbols uh the capital the white house
maybe the washington monument and these
are the real national symbols i think
he's going after them
it doesn't make sense to say that
that they don't have a regard for human
life they didn't they didn't kill
anybody
to say that they uh have a disdain for
pluralism i'm not sure about that
the
trump coalition whatever you want to say
about them pretty pluralistic they came
from all sorts of backgrounds
this was really tasteless this was
really tasty george bush usually tries
to
keep it very urbane and you know above
but he's so above everything he won't
even show up to the republican
convention anymore but this was really
tasteless to use the 20th anniversary of
911 to attack what i don't think i'm
being unfair in interpreting that as an
attack on his political opponents on the
right who were the very same people who
voted for him and who gave him his
political career
and who do not deserve to be compared to
al qaeda they don't deserve to be
compared to blm blm is much much worse
than than they are and they've done many
worse things than anything they've ever
done bush just sounds like a big lib
which i guess he always kind of was i
mean the bush family i'm not even i
don't mean this as some personal attack
on the bush family they were always the
liberal republican family they were the
there were the reaganites and the
bushies and that's why in 1980 reagan
picked bush to be his vp it's not
because they agree they didn't agree on
very much of anything
in fact bush coined the phrase voodoo
economics to make fun of ronald reagan
they ran a bitter primary but reagan
picked him to unify the party reagan
almost didn't endorse him in in 1988
there it's not like there was
a particularly close friendship between
these two guys okay and
george w ran as a more conservative
candidate than his father did but in in
his actual presidency he was
very progressive he was a he was a
wilsonian progressive more wilsonian
probably than woodrow wilson and that
and now we're seeing once again
he's going back to his roots and siding
with the libs over the people who gave
him his political career
as a former democrat congressional
candidate
i almost don't want to give her
any
oxygen
i don't want to give give this any more
air than it's already gotten but it ties
in with the broader narrative here pam
keith
tweets out
on on january 6 january 6 2021
september 11 2001 ceased being the worst
thing that happened to america in my
lifetime it's really weird and painful
to process and say that but it's the
truth and quite frankly it's not even
close so this is obviously an absurd
statement made by a very stupid woman
the only reason i mention it and she's
just doing it to get clicks i would
imagine maybe she really believes it but
then you know she's even thicker in
between the ears than i expected she was
or thinner thinner i suppose just the
wind blows right through them
the reason i mention this is that
what george w bush said
about right wingers
is not
is not much softer than what she is
saying about right wingers
it's a reminder that sometimes it's
called the yuna party or the
establishment or the blob or whatever
you want to call it hates you
holds you in contempt
thinks it is so much better than you and
you have no right to to have any say in
the affairs of your own country that
they are so much better than you and
really you know the way the country is
supposed to work is it supposed to be
bushes and clintons and bushes and
clintons and we're just going to be run
by these two
semi-competing sort of cooperating
friendly families of the american
political dynasty
that's what we're hearing there was a
professor at syracuse university she has
since deleted these tweets but
the internet is forever jen jackson is
an assistant professor at syracuse and
political science
and she was very upset with the way that
people are talking about 9 11. so her
biography just to give you a sense of
who this woman is is she's a queer
genderflux androgynous black woman
okay
an abolitionist
abeles refers to slavery which ended 150
years ago
but now you sometimes hear this applied
to prisons so she's she wants to spring
all the criminals from prison and says a
lover of all black people
the
specific omission of white people here
suggests that she probably doesn't love
white people very much she might
actually hate white people but she
really loves black people she goes quote
we have to be more honest about what 9
11 was and what it wasn't it was an
attack on the hetero patriarchal
capitalistic systems that america relies
upon to wrangle other countries into
passivity it was an attack on the
systems that many white americans fight
to protect she's saying that america
deserved it and specifically white
americans deserved it and the blame for
9 11
goes to white americans who invited this
because they're not communists and
because they're not black
and that woman is teaching at syracuse
university
you are going to hear from some squishes
if this story even makes it out you're
going to hear well
academic freedom
academic freedom means that we can't
fire this woman this woman should be
fired and ostracized from polite society
and frankly banished to saint helena
okay
she has no right to teach
she has no right to participate in
polite society
we once understood this i mentioned this
book god and man at yale where i was
very honored to write the new
introduction to the 70th anniversary
edition this is the book that launched
the modern conservative movement the
subtitle is the superstitions of
academic freedom this was the first big
conservative book in the modern
political era and it made fun of
academic freedom we also should make fun
of that it's a it's a joke it's a farce
it's a hoax to quote buckley it is used
only to defend libs for upending our
standards it's never used to defend
conservatives the woman should be fired
and she should never be hired again
and it's just that simple
this even affects the government and the
maryland diversity office an office that
should be abolished
the maryland diversity office plans to
commemorate september 11th uh with a
play
about how we ought to oppose anti-muslim
stereotypes because that's the lesson of
9 11. that's the lesson
that's the real hurt from 9 11 is the
muslim stereotypes that came afterward
not the 3 000 dead americans not their
families not the city of new york not
the country as a whole that's really
still hasn't gotten over 911
no it's the muslim stereotypes that's
that's the issue that's islamophobia
the the play that the diversity office
has since canceled it and maryland
should cancel the diversity office has
uh it said the play explores themes like
islamophobia and exposes the racial and
ethnic prejudices against muslims as i
mentioned
there are not racial prejudices against
muslims because islam is not a race it's
a religion
but because now i mean this is actually
pretty good proof of my argument that
racism is now just a synonym for bad
it's because we can't talk about sin or
evil or vice we don't we lack the moral
and ethical language to do that in
theological language so instead we just
we talk about racism and we call things
that have nothing to do with race
racism like attacks on islam or
criticisms of islam that's now racist
thankfully they scrapped this play
speaking of critical race theory though
which is behind a lot of what you're
you're seeing from these places
chris ruffo you know chris ruffo is the
manhattan institute scholar
who really popularized this campaign
against critical race theory he's
responsible for a lot of ordinary
americans going out to the school boards
and saying get this crap out of the
classroom
women like the my new favorite woman in
america who's
who says that she's not joe biden's hoe
and he's not going to send her to the
boulevard you know ordinary people who
are waking up and saying i don't like
what's going on
chris ruffo
was just unverified on twitter
unverified
he wasn't suspended he wasn't banned
it's just he used to have a blue check
mark
which means you know you're the real
chris ruffa you get a blue check mark if
there are like fake accounts like i mean
i've had i've had one for years and the
way the reason i got it was i had a
little tiny bit of a public profile but
it was because there were fake nose
accounts so they said okay you put the
check and that's how we know you're the
real you it's not it's not supposed to
be at least any symbol of merit or
valor or anything like that just to
verify who you are so chris lost it
and i messaged chris i said oh chris you
know i always suspected you're not
really who you are
i always know what did he
did he stop being chris ruffo they did
this to this white identitarian some
years ago richard spencer they didn't
kick him off but they took away his
checkmark what did he stop being richard
spencer did he no this is just a way of
saying
we don't like you we want to suppress
your reach it's the beginning of a
social credit system in america
we don't have time to get to it but a
lot more evidence of the social credit
system
in america
not so different from what we read about
in china maybe we'll have time to get to
it tomorrow in the meantime don't give
up keep fighting back for right now it
looks like it's working i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles you'll
see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nica geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show